the Southern California campground where
Tristan Beaudette was mysteriously
killed is now closed
indefinitely he was shot before dawn
last Friday while camping with his two
young daughters detectives are reviewing
other recent unsolved shooting incidents
in Malibu Creek State Park it's part of
their investigation Carter Evans is at
the sheriff's station in Calabasas near
this State Park Carter good morning good
morning and expert we spoke with says
detectives here are looking at every
possible scenario to find out why
tristan Beaudette was shot and now
they're asking for the public's help to
find the shooter the entire campground
area of Malibu Creek State Park is
off-limits to the public until further
notice
investigators are sifting for any clues
into the mysterious shooting of Tristan
beau dead he was camping with his two
and four year old daughters when he was
shot about 4:45 Friday morning they have
an active shooter out there Mary Ellen
O'Toole is director of the forensic
science program at George Mason
University while local law enforcement
is releasing limited information about
their investigation O'Toole says
detectives are likely searching for
clues in BO debts background and the
campsite itself
they'll be attempting to see what type
of weapon was used in this shooting and
then if that weapon was somehow
connected to other shootings especially
ones that took place in that park
sheriff's investigators confirmed to CBS
News there were three other shooting
incidents in the area one just four days
before Beaudette was shot and two more
in June in July of last year those are
now under review as part of the current
homicide investigation earlier a
sheriff's lieutenant told us of a
shooting on Monday morning as well but
now the department will not confirm that
date Beau debts brother tells our Los
Angeles affiliate KCBS he understood
there were two holes in the tent but
it's unclear whether they were bullet
holes at this point it would be too
speculative to say what those holes
represented the offender has to be very
worried that this was in a very busy
location and he cannot be sure who hurt
him or who saw him or even once sent he
left behind
now because authorities are releasing so
little information it's really unclear
how safe the park and surrounding area
is right now authorities say they have
increased patrols and Bo debts family
says they believe this was a random
shooting and that he was not targeted
John Carter thanks